welcome back to CBS this morning we're
gonna begin with this a CBS News
investigation uncovers a possible
pay-for-play scheme involving president
Trump's ambassador nominee to the
Bahamas it raises questions about
whether diplomatic posts are for sale
the impeachment inquiry has shed new
light on how big political donors can
receive ambassadorships Gordon Sandlin
the ambassador to the European Union
donated a million dollars to president
Trump's inauguration the Trump
administration has appointed political
supporters to keep posts abroad in
higher numbers and previous
administrations are Jim Axelrod has been
investigating Jim good morning what you
learn well Toni emails obtained by CBS
new to show the Republican National
Committee as the nominee to be the
ambassador to the Bahamas San Diego
developer Doug Manchester to donate half
a million dollars as his confirmation in
the Senate hung in the balance when
Hurricane durian ravaged the Bahamas in
September
Doug Manchester wanted to help I've had
a home there and I love the water and
the boating and the people so the San
Diego real estate developer who prefers
the nickname Papa Doug loaded up his
private jet with supplies and headed for
the hard-hit Caribbean country where he
hope to soon be serving as US ambassador
you know Papa Douglas he's your big guy
in town folks he's great following the
president's 2016 win manchester donated
a million dollars to mr. trump's
inauguration fund he was offered the
Bahamas post the day after mr. Trump was
sworn in matter of fact he says father
Doug he says you know what I should
probably be an ambassador of Bahamas and
you should be president for two and a
half years Manchester's nomination
stalled but his relief trip caught mr.
Trump's attention the president tweeted
I would also like to thank Papa Doug
Manchester hopefully the next ambassador
to the Bahamas you must loved reading
that tweet I did it wasn't only the
Bohemians who sought his generosity
three days after the tweet Republican
National Committee chairwoman Rhonda
McDaniel hit up Manchester for a
donation did you feel like they were
putting the arm on you
no I didn't that's part of politics it's
unbelievable you're giving you're giving
you give and you give some
more and more and more and it was no
small sum in an email obtained
exclusively by CBS News McDaniel asked
Manchester would you consider putting
together $500,000 worth of contributions
from your family to ensure we hit our
ambitious fundraising goal does any
party feel if you had just cut the check
for $500,000 but you would be the
ambassador to the Bahamas no because
first of all you have to get out of
committee you have to be voted on the
floor is it's a big process a process
that he quickly addressed he wrote back
to McDaniels requests for half a million
dollars as you know I'm not supposed to
do any but my wife is sending a
contribution for $100,000 assuming I get
voted out of the Foreign Relations
Committee on Wednesday to the floor we
need you to have the majority leader
bring it to a majority vote once
confirmed I our family will respond you
know what this looks like well looks
like it to you but my wife gave out of
separate funds and she in fact loves
Donald Trump the suggestion that a
nominee needs to donate in order to be
confirmed is that something you've
encountered over the course of your
career before I have not former
ambassador Barbara Stevenson sir
presidents of both parties for more than
three decades we showed her the email
exchange between Manchester and McDaniel
what do you make it a serious erosion of
the concept that my country doesn't sell
public office it is a bipartisan
tradition for presidents to give about a
third of ambassadorships to political
supporters but our investigation found
they make up nearly half of mr. Trump's
picks new songs we're sitting ambassador
to the UK Woody Johnson an ambassador to
France Jamie McCourt have already given
hundreds of thousands to the president's
2020 reelection fund
Oh Robin Bernstein who serves in the
Dominican Republic and landmarks in
South Africa I started a connection with
five
both have been members of mr. Trump's
mar-a-lago club where it cost $200,000
just to join I really thank you for
considering my nomination we had
concerns of just about judgment about
demeanor bob Corker was the chair of the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee and
before he retired in January held up
Manchester's nomination we told him
about Ronnie McDaniels half-million
dollar fundraising pitch the timing of
that request obviously was was not
appropriate even worse he says was
Manchester's response his big mistake
was copying staffers of two senators who
controlled his nomination Kentucky's
Rand Paul and Idaho's Jim Risch the
chairman of the committee and alerting
them to his willingness to donate more
after confirmation I can only tell you
that if I had received an email like
that there would have been a five Bell
alarm of that head that went off and
that is exactly what happened
Senator Risch notified the White House
which then asked Manchester to withdraw
he officially pulled out last month
citing personal reasons I love our
president I love our country
so how painful was it to have to
withdraw hey listen
politics is politics a lot of McDaniel
declined our interview request but in a
statement the RNC told us the chairwoman
did not suggest mr. Manchester in any
way that it would more quickly advances
confirmation if members of his family
made a political contribution the RNC
says mr. Manchester's decision to link
future contributions to an official
action was totally inappropriate
they said they have cut ties with him
and returned the money his family
donated earlier this year yeah you
wonder if the mistake was putting it on
an email or if it was an actual
violation of policy you know what what
people think is yeah I mean as you point
out there is a history of you know
particular benefactors getting
ambassadors yes public it's usually been
about 35% now it's closer to half sound
like draining the swamp we near that
particular side say that they want it to
be different than it has been sounds
like it's more the same
going up Jim thank you on today's CBS
this morning podcast Jim shares new
details on his investigation listen
wherever you get your podcasts